how do you write a screenplay in a week
so I stick to the three pages a day Rule
and then if the story just starts
flowing then it'll start flowing on its
own and I kind of let that take its
place and then when I start feeling
fatigued I stop because when you're
fatigued you're not gonna do yourself
Justice
so if you think about a week 90 pages
15 20 Pages you can knock that out if
you're in a flow
you have to just keep doing it every day
just do it when you find those Pockets
what I would do is I'd work work work
when I'd have a breathing room because
no one's working eight hours straight
non-stop unless you're like doing road
work or something for the most part you
have your little break Bubbles and what
I would do during my break bubbles is I
would shift and I would write so I'd
write like a page or two and then I'd go
back to work and then I'd write another
page or two and go back to work so I
would be consistently outputting because
the story like as I'm working on this
thing and I'm doing this the story's in
my head so when I'm working on it I'm
thinking about the story like okay this
character can go here okay boom then
I'll go here and I write so it's just
about utilizing those pockets of free
time to write and it again if you stick
to the three pages a day 30 days you
have a full feature film but if you did
six now you got it in 15 if you did nine
you have it in pretty much about seven
days
you said that the stories once you get
started pretty much writes itself have
you ever had it where the story is not
writing itself and you know okay this
isn't going anywhere no
um because I'm not concerned with making
it like someone else's story
I'm not concerned with and now we're all
going to pull from what we're influenced
by our favorite movies like you're gonna
you're gonna have similar stories but
when I write
I like the bad guy winning sometimes I
like you know
things happening that you just don't see
coming
so when I write there's the only
structure really there's only one thing
that I follow as my guide in my draw I'm
not a master writer there's this this is
not a master class but the one thing I
follow is what's making these characters
move forward
what's making these characters move
forward and what I notice is a lot of my
films they all take place within two
days
so as an indie filmmaker it's a lot
easier to shoot two days because people
don't really have to change outfits like
people can wear the same thing in two
days so you're able to save that
um
and you're able to tell a blip of a
story within that two days so if you
have to do a period piece or something
that takes over a year or two years or
you don't know how many days then
there's a lot of things that you add as
far as complexity so I kind of steer
away from that and I do like stories
that are within a small space and the
reason why I don't get hung up on
something is because I kind of just let
it go and whatever happens is whatever
happens
um
if it's received well it's received well
if it's not it's not but what you do
know when you watch it is huh
that's a unique take on it that's
interesting that's not what I would like
let's say if you're a writer watching it
that's not what I would I was taught to
write because there should be more back
and forth conflict like if I watch a
movie and you're able to take somebody
out
it drives me crazy when like let's say
you beat up the bat like Michael Myers
you beat him up and you get in the car
and then you drive off like run them
over 10 times like run them over and
then like make sure he's good and then
drive off
uh in my stories it's very like kind of
like linear it's like okay we're gonna
get from point A to point D and we're
gonna go here and what is what's
allowing these characters to go here and
that's just the process that I use
and for me it's it's been working
because I've been able to get out
stories now whether they're the best or
they're not the only thing that I ever
try to do and this is from an acting
standpoint uh writing standpoint
filmmaking is I just try to make things
that are entertaining I don't care about
winning Awards I don't care about being
the best actor can I get you entertained
can I get you to laugh once can I get
you to be like oh that was cool oh I
like that oh no get that again if I can
get you to do that once within that film
I did my job outside of that
I I don't chase Perfection because I
don't think Perfection is real you can
have masterpieces absolutely but there's
Beauty
in the imperfections so
I think it's more important to get out
that vision
than to wait for everything to be
perfect or for you to create Perfection
because what happens
if you're able to create Perfection for
90 but you're not able to finish
a hundred percent and you have something
that's been sitting there for 10 15
years and now you've gotten into a point
in your life where you're in this rhythm
you're in this routine and you weren't
able to finish your perfection
I think it's better to get it out and
get it done and get better and get
better and and get master your craft and
get better and kind of learn from the
mistakes that you make evolve enhance
influence Inspire other people
and with that you're able to create more
and I think it's more important to have
20 shots
at this dream that we're all pursuing
than to have one shot
and I like my odds better at 20 shots
how do you organize scenes and structure
a screenplay Okay so
90 pages
I don't really go by arcs
so if you go back to okay what's driving
them forward you have this this mission
right whatever it is that drives them
forward
as an indep me writing it as an indie
filmmaker I know that I can't go super
crazy
because I have to be able to capture it
so I can't do cars exploding drifting
off of a bridge into a helicopter like I
can't do that not to say that I can't
but I'm limited at that moment in time
and space to accomplish that so
when I write I write what's feasible
I write 90 pages I don't write 120 130
and I have to chop away it's 90 page I
write what I know I can film and what
I'm going to film
um and then I write locations that I I'm
pretty confident that I can procure and
then once that's done I break the scenes
down by location
so if I have 15 locations in the film
then each location is associated with a
scene number so then now when I go to
that location I know we're doing scene 7
29 and 3. and then the actors all know
okay we're doing 7 29 and three because
that's what's associated with this
location so when you break down scenes
and scripts this way by locations and
the scenes associated with those uh
locations
and you take away the magic Allure of it
and you just put in the work because in
reality all we're doing is lighting
audio and we're push and record that's
it you take away the thought of I need
20 crew members I need a PA I need a I
need this I need that take all that away
and just think about what is the work
the work is to capture your story in
front of the lens to the best of your
ability at that time
so once you're able to do that and
you're able to break it down into these
sections now you know okay I have 15
locations
I have 15 shoot days so let's plan
around these 15 shoe days we have three
scenes six scenes two scenes I have four
hours two hours three hours
now you've created a plan
on how to shoot your film
now those are just consistent small
steps that you do non-stop then when you
get to that last location and you shoot
those scenes you're now done and you're
working on the post-production on
editing color grading sound design
voices and you're doing all of that but
as far as shooting because you created a
plan on how you were going to do it
and you were consistent about it
you did it
and that's kind of how I break down
films I break down films by scenes and
locations and I tie them together so
then when I get a location if I have to
do 10 scenes
in three hours I know we have to fly
there's no there's no Double Take triple
take we gotta fly but if I have one
scene for one location I can get 100
shots and take my time with it so you'll
have some scenes that turn out better
than others because you had more time
with it
but it's better to have a completed film
and continue to get better
than to just try and get that perfect
shot and then now instead of a 16 15
shoot day you have a 50 60 shoot day
that took three or four years
because you didn't plan
how did you create the character of Ace
in four Leos
so Ace
four Amigos
pose a lot of influence from Fast and
the Furious
um I think any film with cars pulls from
fast and Affairs but Ace is is almost
like
Paul Walker's character but Asian
um
I just wrote what I wanted to see on
screen and I pulled from the things that
I love
one of the main things that I've loved
since I was a teenager is cars in the
car culture and the car community
and they are so abrasive of each other
right it doesn't matter if you have a
fifteen hundred dollar Honda Civic that
you built up in your garage or you have
uh 80 000 CA Corvette it just doesn't
matter like there's love for cars which
turns into love for people
so with Asus character I knew okay what
could I do to move the story forward
what can I shoot
that's
feasible
from where I am currently at in life
I said okay his mom is sick and he has
to rob somebody
how can I incorporate cars
without making it you know have cheesy
card dialogue and stuff
and my dialogue is very simple because
it's really my my films are more
I think story driven
and the characters are kind of just
develop compared to character driven and
then the story develops so I'm more
interested in the story
of how did they get from point A to
point d right how did it get there and
with Ace I was like okay how can I
how can I make him
get to where he's trying to get to and
incorporate cars that was the main thing
because I had access to these cars these
amazing cars and I knew that I had a
higher level of success with the niche
film right so like
if I was going to make a film about cars
I know there's an audience a
multi-billion dollar audience attached
to that
and I I own all the Fast and the Furious
Blu-rays I watch like all of them yearly
I'll go and just do a Marathon run
because I just love cars and I love car
films and car culture so by me uh Not Me
By Us creating a tuner film
we automatically had that Niche audience
because I know they're going to want to
see the NSX The Supercharged BRZ these
cars I know they're going to want to see
it so by having that Niche audience we
have a greater level and greater chance
of success
so then it was just about incorporating
my character into that space how can I
get him into a
action-esque film how can I give him the
biggest chance to succeed and when I
write these scripts and I write these
stories I write myself in mind for parts
that I want to see someone like myself
play
um
so by having that connection to his mom
anybody can relate because anybody would
do anything to help save their mom or
their dad so that already connects to
the human portion of of who we are then
to go rob the bad guy I painted the bad
guys a real bad guy so when things
happen throughout the story or when
things happen at the end you were like
yeah he was so nasty I'm so glad they
got him and then for the good guys to
win even though I do like the bad guys
winning in this particular story it was
about the good guys winning and then
setting up the sequel
um
there's a lot of scenes where cars are
in the film way longer than a normal
film would have had them because I knew
car guys just want to see those shots so
I left them in there but it was really
about just kind of like a hero's journey
um about a guy that is into car culture
that saves his mom